[Music]
Christmas definitely one of the craziest
fancies make up this get up is like no
mother
[Music]
they're always up for pictures and
they're yelling goats oops and you cry
here before you see them Annie Reed has
been one of the greatest thing that's
ever happened to us
besides Patti the economic impact in
Jurassic that area around the stadium
now is I mean you should have seen it
like ten years ago there was nothing out
there
there's definitely been a boom and not
just housing but the updating of
existing housing I really think that
Kansas City as a whole has got better
there's more businesses growing here
the economy has raised substantially
there's more people going to Arrowhead
and there's more people trying to move
out by arrowhead I mean my best buddy
suit got a house I'm from Kansas City
and when I graduate high school and I
finally moved out every single Sunday I
would go to Stannis that's when I
started meeting people and like making
friends
[Music]
that's the tailgate is everything it's
like an ocean of pavement and you've got
so many people from so many walks of
life it's just a family it really is
how could I be away from the Chiefs like
I can't have it even if I moved I be
you'd have to pay me ten million dollars
to move somewhere else and I would still
fly out here for every game Kansas City
is beautiful and not a lot of people
know that but then when they come to
town is up to us to treat them right
have manners offer them stuff and just
make sure they have a good time you got
all religions all walks of life and once
we score a touchdown nothing matters
it's all about high-fives
cheering and standing up getting loud
and third-down been applied in one thing
and one bill and that's the way I
couldn't move any where else and I've
talked to my girlfriend about this if we
get married you know I was like we can't
leave here like this is it this is home
[Applause]
[Music]